last week a tu saksad interception this  week I've had a past offense but I hurt  my groin but then coach said did you say  alcohol I gotta run your brother's here  you know he's raised 37 million dollars  he's a GD angel get it mom I'll never be  as good as JJ well that's the first  problem trying to be cool  stop trying to be bad who the Steelers  and we're nasty nasty oh okay like like  Big Ben no no no no like that that's  nice kid after this we're gonna buy you  some nasty-ass sweatpants and shoot  videos of us doing 700-pound pelvic  thrusts TJ what's going on here get out  of here JJ I'm the NASA Steeler boy now  you were a lot and watts do not upset to  do so sorry I'm not perfect JJ maybe cuz  around you I feel like the forgotten why  well now hold on who do you  I'm Derek why and I play fullback on the  Chargers in Los Angeles so check your  wot privilege so sorry